excusez moi monsieur je crois que vous
vous trompez de voitures plusieurs mails
deux jours de suite pour avoir un rendez
vous dites moi ce qui vous arrive
je n'ai jamais vu un cas semblable 23
identité vivent dans le corps de kevin
dites moi ce qui fait passer les fleurs
sur les oreillers il ya une fleur dans
la salle de bain doit avoir de
l'importance c'est qui ça elle peut-être
nous aider
ne vous inquiétez pas il sait pourquoi
vous êtes ici il lui est interdit de
toucher à vous il le sait je m'appelle
est pire gd chauffer trouves tu as quel
âge 9 ans le cerveau humain est l'objet
le plus complexe de l'univers
la seule façon de tirer d'ici 2012
d'études de nous laisser sortir c'est
toi la plus maline tu pourrais nous et
et week
ok il ya une fenêtre dans ma chambre tu
vas bien nous la montrer regarde là elle
fermée là elle est ouverte a cru que
c'était une vraie fenêtre et que tu
pourrais t'en as vu un individu la
personnalité multiple peut modifier sa
physiologie par la force de la pensée
quelqu'un va venir vous chercher
que se passera-t-il quand il libérera
tout le potentiel de son cerveau il n'y
a pas de limite à ce qu'il peut devenir
cette nuit est sacrée vous allez être en
présence de quelque chose de plus
grandiose le monde va comprendre
maintenant
la bête existe
elle a fait des choses horribles à des
gens elle va vous faire aussi des choses
horribles